as a fired FBI director prepares to
testify the man chosen to replace him is
also in the spotlight today Christopher
Rea is a well-established Washington
lawyer who was an assistant attorney
general under president george w bush
ray led the Justice Department's
criminal investigation while Comey was
Deputy Attorney General Jeffrey gazes
outside FBI headquarters with that part
of the story Jeff good morning good
morning if confirmed Ray's steps into
one of the toughest jobs in Washington
right now the FBI is facing public
scrutiny and there is uncertainty ahead
FBI insiders say commis firing left a
hole in the bureau if confirmed as its
next director chris Ray's mission would
be to bring stability to the FBI and
it's more than 35,000 employees
President Trump who interviewed ray on
May 30th says he is an impeccably
qualified individual and a fierce
guardian of the law he understands how
to operate under crises he understands
how the agency works
rosco Howard a former US attorney worked
with Ray at the DOJ I'd be shocked if he
had some sort of political agenda it's
just not the chris ray i've come to know
a graduate of yale law
ray is a former assistant US attorney in
the Northern District of Georgia just
before 9/11 he became associate Deputy
Attorney General and later moved on to
head the Justice Department's Criminal
Division last year Ray's served as Chris
Christie's lawyer hired to navigate the
Bridgegate scandal
I commend the president for
extraordinary choice former Justice
Department officials spoke highly of ray
describing him as the right man at the
right time for the nation and the FBI a
person of extraordinary integrity and
someone who simply doesn't make mistakes
ray will likely take charge as a law
enforcement source tells CBS News in
general this is not a great time at the
FBI
Roscoe Howard says it's clear the agency
is bracing for a challenging transition
I think we'd all be foolish not to think
there's some element of
going on is it chaotic sure but is it
any more chaotic than 911 my guess is no
the perception here in Washington is
that rain will maintain a lower profile
than James Comey but that will be tough
to do with a congress that has a
voracious appetite for testimony
especially when it comes to the Russia
investigation Charlie
Jeff thanks